[Applause]
keep it going for a chance everybody
yeah man what's going on everybody we
all good
yeah well first of all thank you so much
for coming out to the show tonight
welcome welcome welcome i want to let
you all know real quick for those of you
who came to see some really intelligent
life-altering comedy you've come to the
wrong show
if you're here to turn your brain off
for like an hour and a half and laugh at
some [__] silly [__]
welcome to my world here we are you know
what i mean
now i do want to say before we get
started uh
so we just moved from california
and um we're that's all it deserves um
we uh
we're not quite used to the humidity yet
it is anybody else not used to
humidity walking around it's crazy
here's how you know by the way
you're in a city that has a lot of
humidity
because i saw dudes walking down the
street today like this
you're going to shake it off your leg
one time in nashville it is [__]
sticky sack season here i'll tell you
what
it was stuck to my leg like a fruit roll
up all day today
and on both sides like a bat on the wall
nah i'm looking out i did see a couple
of women
don't hey don't ooh if you see a guy do
this don't you ooh
he didn't stick his hand he didn't
he didn't stick his hands down his pants
this dude
he's a gentleman
you see a dude do this you tip your hat
and you say good day sir to that guy and
you let him walk by
i'll tell you something else too and
this is it ladies we love you but i
can't i can't hear one more woman
complain about watching a dude adjust
himself in public i can't hear it's so
hypocritical especially considering down
on broadway today i was only there for a
half an hour i saw at least six women in
jean shorts do this
[__] you and your hair [__] you
[Applause]
you guys go in with two hands too
and you make eye contact you're
confident you're like what [__] you what
you know
one woman went in deep deep i swear when
she went like this i heard him i heard i
swear i did
like you know like you're opening some
biscuits or something
i can't hear it anymore you know
well happy father's day everybody happy
father's day
now um
oh thank you so much i appreciate that
now
i have a lot of favorite stories about
all my kids but this one is my absolute
favorite story about my youngest son
and um
so here's a couple things you need to
know about him going in first of all
my youngest son
here's what i love the most about him
no matter where he is
that's the best place he's ever been
yo that dude does not know how to have a
bad time he look and it's a great i envy
that attitude doesn't and by the way
look his energy is crazy i could put him
down at any of your tables he could talk
to any of you for an hour and you'd be
like i know this dude for a decade like
it's crazy that kind of
i don't even know if you call it a skill
but it's it's born you know
he is also the dumbest of my three kids
now he's not dumb i'm not saying he's
dumb but who has multiple kids in here
anybody have multiple kids
hey
look if you've got multiple kids
you've got a dumb one too that's all i'm
saying
they may not be stupid but there's a
stupidest one out of all of them that's
the dumb one and i'm going to tell you
something else
if you got more than one kid you have
had this conversation with your partner
in the bedroom
what the [__] are we gonna do with the
dumb one
we gonna let him walk out there by
himself he's so [__] stupid you know
what i mean
here's my favorite story about my son
so
uh a long time ago a long time ago um
when i was a single guy i used to take
the kids down to mexico
and um on day trips and because mexico i
lived in southern california it was
cheap you could go down there fifty
dollars
it's a new culture you know what i mean
it's a new country and super cool
adventure you know
so
but you couldn't go until you were seven
so by the time jakey turned seven i was
married and but he was like i want to go
to mexico and i said cool and he was
guys driving down to mexico he was
pumped
the whole way right just [__]
pointing things out he's like is that
mexico i'm like no that's home depot
but we're driving down there we get to
mexico
we're there for about an hour
and he turns to me he goes ha dad
i love by the way he has always stood
like forrest gump i have no idea why
this dude has always he used to he was a
great baseball player he hit a double
and slide into second and you pop up
like
this and always
paul is always like great hit buddy put
your hands down great
not bad
so we're there for an hour and he goes
dad i love mexico
everybody here is so smart and i was
like
what makes you say that man he goes
they all know how to speak spanish
and i was like oh
come here you dumb [__] okay
daddy's gonna take care of you for as
long as he has to i guess
you're going to live with me till you're
40. aren't you buddy
we were there for another hour
and this dude decides he can speak
spanish
because to him it sounds like this
[Applause]
and i go hey man hey hey
i said do not
speak the spanish
and he goes no i know how to speak it i
go no you don't i don't
so we walk around for a while we end up
going to a restaurant you know
and we sit down and the dude drops two
menus and in english
he says to me
what can i get you to drink i said i
would love a modelo please he said
absolutely and in english
he says to my son
what can i get you to drink young man
my son's looking at the menu and he's
like
[Applause]
what are you saying to this dude
and he walks away i go jakey what'd i
tell you man do not speak the spanish
and he goes no i know how to talk it i
go no
and he got really cocky he goes
he took my order
i was like you said the word coke bro
you know what i mean
i said listen man i know you don't
understand this and i don't i know you
don't mean to but you're insulting this
man's culture and his heritage and his
language and you're doing it right to
his face and i'm telling you right now
that's not okay so under no circumstance
are you two speak the spanish ever again
do you understand me and he goes yes dad
so we finish off our food right
and uh because i tell him not to speak
to spanish he's sulking and he's like i
just want to go home
i said all right he goes can i lay down
in the back seat and go to sleep and i
was like sure
so we're driving up to the border
and uh the border patrol guy
he says to me he goes uh
can i see your id and i said yeah and he
goes
great he said he got a birth certificate
for the kid
i said no
why do i need a birth certificate for my
kid
and he said well
i got to make sure every child that
leaves mexico is a mexican
how do i know he's not mexican and i was
like
so i said jj
speak to spanish
[Applause]
this dude's head popped up from the back
seat
[Music]
and the guy just looked at me and he
looked at him and he was like
have a great day
we're driving out of mexico right
15 minutes no we neither one of us said
anything and he's just looking out the
back window and it's rolled down he's
got the wind blowing in his face
and i just hear him mumble under his
breath
i told you i know how to speak spanish
[__] dick
now listen guys uh if you've never seen
my show or know much about me
i enjoy weird [__]
uh i enjoy things that are a little
different i enjoy fun and energy and i
will tell you a lot of weird things have
been happening at my shows
and i think i kind of invited uh
it started and i'll tell you when it
started it started about four years ago
i don't know if any of you have been on
my youtube channel and have seen
have you seen the video
about the woman throwing up in her
margarita cup
okay so i just need to give you guys
okay all right
for those of you who haven't seen this
video this is an actual video it
happened
i just happened to be filming my set
that night i was on stage at a casino in
connecticut called mohegan son i was
just filming you can see this video on
my youtube channel
and i was talking to this side of the
room
and from behind me right here
i just heard
and i turn and i look back and there's a
woman sitting right here staring at me
like this
and i was like oh
my god
and i didn't want to throw her out
because obviously she wanted to be at
the show you know what i mean so
but i i was like i wonder what she's
going to do with that you know
they were drinking these giant
margaritas she had an empty cup in front
of her
this is all on video guys
she grabs the cup she slowly brings it
to her like this
staring at me the whole time and just
goes
like
like she was feeding a baby bird
it was some prison [__] she just stuck
but i was like all right you know i'll
tell you we want another real reason i
wasn't worried i don't know if any of
you have tried to throw up in your mouth
before that's not easy and the fact that
nothing came out the sides i was like
well she's done this before so
i don't need to worry about her she's a
professional you know what i mean like
15 minutes later again all on video
talking over here again and i hear
and there she is
her friend who's sitting right next to
her
i see her lean over
and i think she's gonna say
hey
we should get you out of here
but she leans over and she goes hey
get your [__] together
that's a good friend by the way that's a
good friend
a bad friend is you're doing great this
is great a good friend is you're a
[__] grown-up get your [__] together
you shouldn't be throwing up in public
you're 40 sally that's a good friend
i'll tell you the weirdest maybe the
weirdest thing that's happened at one of
my shows and then we'll get into it
happened about three weeks ago in
indianapolis
so okay uh
so i was talking to the crowd and i said
who's got kids and there was a man and a
woman there who were clearly together
arms around each other
whispering in each other's ears nibbling
on each other and i'm like oh look at
this this is a couple loves each other
you know
and i go how many kids you got and the
dude goes i got i got three boys
i go and the girl the woman goes i got
one girl and i go
are you not married
and she goes oh we're married and i go
and the guy goes just not to each other
and i was like what
now
i i thought it was gonna be like they're
cute you know they were both separated
and that's how they get into talking
about each other they were both married
right so i was like oh i go so the other
the other
your partners i mean they know you're
here together right the guy goes i
[__] hope not
and i said dude
you're so confident talking about this
in front of a room full of people
and he goes
yeah i live an hour from here i don't
know any of these people
and then from the back of the room in
the dark
you just hear a guy go i know you mark
and i was like oh
[Applause]
you're [__] bro you're [__]
anyways guys i have to tell you how
excited i am for this show tonight not i
i i'm gonna tell you a little something
about me man
as an artist one thing that i love to do
is i love to challenge myself i love to
do things i've never done before it's
really how i keep that energy of doing
this all the time
to play guitar on stage and be able to
do this um
is such a crazy opportunity i feel so
lucky to be here with you guys tonight
so thank you all so cool so much for
coming and sharing this with me
[Applause]
i
can remember an hour and a half of my
stand up i can't remember the songs so
that's the set list right there
um and so uh so i had always wanted to
um i got some parodies i got some
originals
i had always wanted to uh
write a song about a dude with man boobs
so uh
is this is this good where the mic is
that's what the [__] i'm about to do bro
i think i sat down with a guitar in
front of a microphone bro oh you mean
play something so he can hear it yeah
yeah oh you gotta go sorry for being an
[__] okay
[Music]
okay
listen guys here's a couple things now
one of the reasons i'm nervous doing
this in nashville is because there's
probably some musicians in the crowd i
do not want you to be offended by by my
guitar play
the reason that this isn't plugged in is
because when i plug the guitar in i find
you can really hear what it sounds like
[Laughter]
so way better i like my guitar micah
jason
look at you two guys how old are you
guys
18.
that's how both of you laugh i've never
met you before but i know you both go
[Music]
we'll get back to you guys later
what
song about a dude with man boobs
here we go
[Music]
big old titties
on
i had to get that out okay here we go
wiggle titties
on my friend damn
never seen a c cup look so good on a man
[Music]
[Applause]
all right here we go
at the swimming pool putting on some
suntan lotion
greasing up those bad boys in a
roundabout motion
you know dan he could win a wet t-shirt
contest
ariel's like salami
nipples like sausage
[Music]
in a couple of years they're gonna swing
to his back
and oh yeah dan's got a nice old
rag i wonder if he knows they make me
tingle in my sack
[Music]
come on dre
he's got nuts
and a dick
[Applause]
never seen a c-cup look so good on the
map
[Applause]
give it up for dre everybody one time
now
i i told you i liked weird [__]
[Applause]
hey man did you suck a titty
maybe i should have saved that to the
end i don't know
follow that
wait till you see what the next guy
whips out
[Applause]
all right
so
my uh
my buddy called me not too long ago
and um he was like man i gained a bunch
of weight over quarantine and i
developed a very specific problem
will you write a song about it and i
said absolutely
here you go
well i gained a few pounds
belly's big and round
i lost my junk under my gut
thanks to the rona
i can't see my boner
i'm sorry that's so stupid
[Applause]
okay hold on
thanks to the rona i can't see my boner
and my balls are somewhere near my butt
and i saw the surprise in my wife's eyes
when she saw my pubic hair
she said you need a trim i don't know
where to begin but i'll never find waldo
in there
that's all i got right now
appreciate it
um
this next song um
i'm for sure going to lose a couple you
on
but i don't know if you guys any of you
remember that song
my name is luca yeah all right here we
go
oh here we go
i see your fupa
okay you can't laugh at man boobs and
not at fupa that is not okay
either all the jiggly body parts are
funny or none of the jiggly body parts
are funny but you don't get to [__]
pick just because you might have one
doesn't mean that shit's not funny
so either you laugh at both or you
laughing neither but you can't [__]
pick and choose everybody okay
now if you don't know what a fupa is
that's legit ask your neighbor somebody
at the table next to you definitely
knows
do you guys know
neither any one of you know
[Applause]
listen man you know just teaching the
youth the important stuff you know what
i mean
okay
here we go all right
i see your fupa
your [__] has a second floor that's all
i got right now but
i think it's going to be a pretty good
song once i finish it i think that
really is going to be a [__] good one
now it is father's day and then uh
people ask me all the time about
father's day gifts and i think father's
day is super
super interesting man the difference
between father's day and mother's day
you know i'll tell you something right
now you know what i really where the
father's in here round of applause
[Music]
i'll tell you what we all want and i
think this is uh pretty universal
we would like you to leave us the [__]
alone for an entire day
that's it you don't have to do anything
except open the front door and not come
back for a while that's it and you know
the difference between mother's day and
father's day mother's day is like i'm
gonna go to a spa i'm gonna go out with
my friends i'm gonna have a nice dinner
and father's day somehow we're all
[__] doing something together i don't
know how that works
we're going out to your favorite
restaurant this is my favorite
restaurant i had no idea this was my
favorite restaurant i've never [__]
been here before whose favorite
restaurant is this
so um
you know their father's day i just
thought i would sing a couple of uh
you know my kids always asked why i
don't sing songs about them and so
i remember one time they were like can
you sing a song about us and let
everybody know how you feel about us and
i was like yup
this is for the kids
[Music]
children are beautiful they're little
miracles of life
what you've always wanted for you and
your wife
but bless their little souls
children are [__]
and my kids are [__]
[Music]
your kids are [__]
cause all kids are [__]
it's gonna be okay everybody
when you were pregnant oh it looks so
cute then you get them home they just
eat sleep and they poop do you know a
baby can scream like a pterodactyl
for seven hours in a row
nobody tells you that [__]
do you remember disposable income do you
remember you could [__] in the kitchen
so you know the average cost of raising
one kid
is 500 grand and i would sell my kids
for that
i guess i'm not alone on that one holy
[__]
that's why i smoke a ton of weed
[Applause]
cause children are [__]
and my kids are [__]
and your kids are [__]
cause all kids are [__]
unless you're this person not my son
my son's not an [__] he's perfect my
little amethyst are you [__] his
name's amethyst or stone or seed or some
stupid [__] like that
[Applause]
not my little amethyst he's perfect it's
like having another grown-up at the
house he doesn't do anything wrong and
we let him have whatever opinion he
wants because we think it is important
that he expresses himself fully all of
the time and we want him to be a
butterfly and to spread his wings and
just to spread his wings and fly that's
why when you're at a restaurant we let
him run up to you and scream in your
[__] face
because he doesn't have any rules he's a
butterfly fly amethyst fly we want you
to fly air with this fly fly in with his
fly and if you're that person guess what
[Applause]
i see we've all encountered one or two
of those parents before
[Music]
um i will tell you man you know
obviously we all love our kids and
and uh we all have certain things about
our certain kids that we love the most
and
and so one thing that i love the most
about my daughter is my daughter was the
most creative young person i had ever
met and ever come in contact with and
like she you put mac and cheese down in
front of her and she would just do a mac
and cheese or if you gave her a
hamburger she would make that hamburger
talk to you and give it a voice and
we would give her a doll and she would
write a play for the doll and you would
watch it in the living room like a half
an hour later just it was always
creativity and i loved it so when she
was six and a half years old my wife and
i we bought her a cat
and she said i would like to write a
poem about that cat and read it the
talent show
and i said okay
so this is the poem that my daughter
wrote about her cat
that she read in front of the entire
school
[Music]
and i just put it to music
oh i love her my [__]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah my [__] likes to run around my
[__] she makes the cutest sounds
she can be scary
she's really hairy
yeah my [__] sleeps right on my chest
my [__] she likes my brother best my
[__]
she's as happy as can be
[Music]
and she's part of the family
yeah she likes to sleep all over
the place
my [__] she'll lick your face
who my [__] she'll lick your
face
thank you
[Applause]
i want you to know sh when she opened
with who i love with my [__] i turned
to my wife i'm like hey we gotta go
she said why i was like the chorus is my
[__] like
she's going back to it at least a couple
more times we we gotta get the [__] out
of here you know she goes yeah if you
leave she's going to be humiliated i
said yeah but if we stay
we're going to be humiliated
here you know
we stayed my wife is a better person
than i am
so we're waiting outside of the
auditorium for the kids to come out and
the parents come out first and look we
all know we live in a generation with
some judgy [__] parents
and they were streaming out of that
auditorium walking past me like this
and one woman just walked up to me and
she goes you know you really had to
proofread your daughter's poetry
before she reads it in front of the
whole school
and she walked off and her husband
walked up to me and goes your house
sounds fun you just high five
[Applause]
i will tell you man and i love having my
wife here you know what um
and i should probably explain this
look she knows this but
i love bothering her
i do little things to bother her if
you're married to someone and you don't
constantly [__] with them
because here's it's the perfect audience
because where the [__] are they going
you know what i mean
yo i have this one long hair on my
eyebrow that gets real long and i'll lay
in bed next to her and i'll twirl it
like i'm a super villain just like
she [__] hates it you know what else
i do when she's in the bathroom and i
have and i and i take my socks off where
do i put my socks babe
and like 10 minutes in she's like what's
that smell what is that smell
these [__] socks
just so you know ladies when you say
don't do that it bothers us i'm like
well i gotta do this for at least
another month that i guess
so
one of the things that i've always done
to beth is she loves love songs
i love ruining love songs for her
um so what i'll do is i'll write
parodies for songs that she loves so she
never hears the words that she likes
and so this is one of the songs that she
loves and a long time ago a couple years
ago i did some research online
and i found out there are guys out there
who have tiny penises and um
i imagine that those guys get to have
sex every now and then i also imagine
that that sex is probably pretty awkward
for everybody involved so
this is a song about a dude with a tiny
penis having awkward sex and it's from
his point of view and this song is not
about me okay here we go
and guys if we if you don't laugh at
this we're all going to assume why so
yuck it up you tiny dick [__]
here we go
song about a dude tiny penis
awkward sex his point of view not about
me
ready go
say something i'm right on top of you
[Applause]
[Music]
be patient i haven't hit my groove
the least you could do
is kind of move
[Music]
please say something i am inside of you
[Applause]
am i
am i really that
small
[Music]
i've been told that it's skinny but it's
strong
[Music]
and it won't hurt you at all
am i
am i really that
small
maybe your vagina's kinda big
like to put a hot dog down
[Music]
stop tweeting that is just [__] rude
two more pumps
and i'll be through
please say something i am inside you
[Music]
thank you very much
[Applause]
so listen let's start let's get the
screen here's the deal now you guys are
about to watch a video one of the things
that i've been doing here in nashville
it's been a ton of fun with these is
i've been shooting music videos
and uh we shot one a couple weeks ago to
a parody uh we're gonna run in back real
quick uh we're gonna do a quick little
costume change bring a couple guests out
but while i'm back there changing it up
please enjoy this video
i'm gonna get juice real quick this is
kurt chambers on guitar over here
and this is miss taylor lynn
hello
now uh
tayla uh
she came to me about writing a song
together and do you want to tell her
tell everybody why yeah i do you were
the perfect person to come to my
grandmother is loretta lynn and she
writes
[Applause]
she writes her truth and it's my 10-year
anniversary with my husband this year
and we've really been going through
yeah some new stuff we're in a new
period in our marriage
and so i came to josh we could write a
song together she wanted to write a song
about something that her and her husband
had been talking about and i just think
it's probably pretty universal for a lot
of couples
and so uh but i thought i would we would
put it to a song that um that beth liked
also
uh so we could ruin that one as well
yeah
but uh
whenever you're ready i am yeah
yeah oh wait a second oh oh whoa oh
tiger shoe i didn't put my shoes on not
sure because i felt like i should come
out in my uniform feeling just as sexy
as i could i like your sparkling paint
yeah well this is conway twitty's wife's
shirt
well
yeah his widow what's that nothing
[Applause]
all right here we go
what
[Music]
tell me something girl
whatever makes you the most comfortable
and you
told me
[Music]
we could try it on our 10th anniversary
well my
dear
decades up
the time is here
[Music]
tell me something boy
will you go first i'll use a toy
why do you sing scared
you want it so bad it you could go first
it just seems fair
you
told me
[Music]
what's the big deal we do lots of
stuff
[Music]
[Applause]
i was trying to hold it into
[Music]
we're talking
hey
now
[Music]
no no
no
no no no
i'll try a finger
don't let it linger we're talking about
ain't no now
if i'm being honest i'm scared that i
like it we're talking about ain't no
doubt
[Music]
hey
[Applause]
thank y'all so much thank you
oh you were backstage for that part of
the show aren't you
all right um well listen i guess i'm
stuck in this outfit for the rest of the
show
[Applause]
i'll switch back to i'll switch switch
back to the hat that makes me
comfortable um
but i'm gonna play you know i really
love uh
yeah i'm gonna can i get my hat right
now uh
it just feels
[Applause]
um okay so uh
i love dudes who play sexy music and
sing about things that aren't sexy
and so
i wrote a couple of tunes this one i
wrote man um my buddy a while ago he was
like hey
can you make a video with me and put it
on top of my dating profile
it's getting pretty competitive out
there
and i said i don't know what that means
and he was like let's just make a funny
video and put it on top of the dating
profile i go okay
and so we did it and by the way
super funny but nothing he said about
himself was real
and i was like how do you not you don't
tell the truth on day profiles he goes
no nobody does you just he said you just
show up and figure it out and i was like
and he said if you had a dating profile
would you tell the truth about yourself
and i go yeah
and he said would you do a video and i
said no i'd probably write a stupid
little song
so this is the song i would have on top
of my
dating profile to tell you a little
something about me
[Music]
all right
you know that i want you baby
you know that i got you baby
you know that i need you baby
so come let me please you baby
but i [__] with my socks on
[Applause]
and i [__] with my black socks song girl
and i [__] with my socks on
and i [__] with my black socks on
girl
got bad circulation baby
my feet are like ice cubes baby
deep vein thrombosis david
[Music]
i'm on medication baby
that's why i [__] with my side
song
and i [__] with my black sock song girl
a couple other things i should probably
tell you
[Applause]
[Music]
my legs are pale they're almost kinda
light blue
there's a chance that i'll dutch oven
you
oh and my stamina is not what it used to
be so when we bang you gotta get on top
but i'll have my socks on
and
[Music]
i also
shave my
[Music]
now let me just say i want to address
the balls for just a second uh
yo i just want to tell anybody whose
partner insists that they take a
straight blade or a razor
to their balls does not understand the
topography of a nut sack that's all i'm
saying
yo that's like shaving your brain you're
gonna nick that [__] a couple of
times you know what i mean
by the way every guy in here will tell
you that first time you nicked your nuts
you have no idea how much that's going
to bleed do you know me yeah the first
time you nick your nuts you're like am i
about to bleed out is this the end
i put my feet up on my heart i called my
dad i'm like am i about to die man tell
me what the [__]
yeah no not balls bro not ball
[Applause]
shoulder
[Music]
all right one more quick one um okay so
uh
i always find a funny man that whenever
you hear rappers or rock stars sing
about sex it's like everybody has a huge
dick and has sex all night long everyone
i might tell you right now i'm at an age
where if you told me i want to [__] all
night long i'd be like that sounds
terrible
one time in an episode of friends that
i'll see you tomorrow you know what i
mean
but this is what i would think would be
an honest song from a rock star
about what it'd be like to have sex with
him
thanks for coming by
you're looking mighty fine i'll say
you're wearing yoga pants
[Music]
let's do some downward facing dog
come right in and lay your clothes on
the floor
[Music]
by the end of the night girl
[Applause]
um
[Music]
and now you're ready for some
and now you're ready for some more i'm
getting pretty tired
[Applause]
are you ready for the best two minutes
of your life
[Music]
come right in and lay your clothes on
the floor
[Music]
that's not the words
lay you down put on a romantic song
[Music]
you won't have to listen to free bird
that's ten minutes too long
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm gonna start that verse over i'm
[__] up already
here we go i'm not like other guys
i won't waste your whole night
[Music]
i know you're busy girls your schedule's
not the only thing that's tight
and are you ready for someone
[Music]
and now you're
[Applause]
sorry about that let me get you a towel
minutes of your life
[Music]
[Applause]
all right so
now you guys will actually be able to
hear somebody who knows how to play
guitar um but here's the deal so i um
you know there's a certain part of my
body that i'm very proud of and
so i wanted to sing a little sexy song
about it
hold on
[Music]
whenever you're ready
[Applause]
the only day i was born
the doctor said to me
you
are a vision
of what a man should be
[Music]
legs long
thin two
[Music]
you
are the president of the dainty ankle
crew and i am
[Music]
i don't got one
i got to
[Applause]
[Music]
i
look good in high heeled shoes
i am the
the ankle crew
[Music]
now the good looking women
they come up to me
and say hey man
what's below the knee
yeah ladies
believe what you heard
when i take off my pants i look like a
sexy ass bird at all
i don't
[Music]
i know i know you ladies are jealous too
even caitlyn jenner calls me bruce
i am dainty angle crew
[Music]
[Applause]
he's laughing because we've actually
never played together before so
that's how it's true
that's true yeah we've never played here
so
um
so kurt let's um
all right here we go
let me tell you one of the other things
one of the things that i love the most
about my wife
is that she really lets me be me right
and um she also people ask her a lot do
you mind that he smokes weed or so much
weed
and i think she would tell you um
she likes me better when i'm hot
uh
because i
she's like when you don't smoke weed for
a month you never shut the [__] up
so i we wrote a couple of weed tunes
um and uh let's start with this
[Music]
all right
you know i like some weed
let's try that again i'm a little behind
you yeah
okay
go like this when i'm supposed to go in
[Music]
okay
you know i like some weed
[Music]
it's got me super high
let's go get some munchies
pretty sure i can drive
[Music]
let's go to taco bell
get a gordita supreme
drive through mcdonald's
fries in a dream
but i need sweets
[Music]
candy or bakers
too many choices i have
i don't know what i want
i know
some skills
[Music]
ready
where to put my keys
i had them right here
[Music]
do you know where my shoes are
i don't know where my shoes are
you know what
we should just stay here
i'll call postmates
[Music]
do you know where my phone is
i can't find where my phone is
[Applause]
[Music]
i bet you never played with someone
who's supposed to know what they're
doing and go tell me when i'm supposed
to say something
i don't know tell me when i'm supposed
to talk right now
listen guys uh you know one of the
things that i love most about being here
is i have a ton of friends here and i
have a ton of creative friends who like
to come around and [__] around with me
and do weird [__] i have another one of
my friends in back
uh ladies and gentlemen from nsync mr
chris kirkpatrick everybody
[Applause]
oh yeah are we out here come on up man
come on there he is
chris kirkpatrick everybody
[Applause]
you're the only person here that
i don't understand how we're friends
like i sat here all night going i can go
out the back and no one will ever know i
was ever here just tell josh don't call
me up because this is getting ridiculous
tonight
hey guys i'm gonna do a set about weed
let me bring my instinct buddy up
hey
come on up did you did you see him put
dre's titty in his mouth
i don't think you saw it i i i'm not you
i saw the whole thing and i i just
looked i was like i was gonna send some
sympathy cards to dre yeah because i
know dre was trying to be funny and
yeah i don't know what's going on right
here but y'all are out of control
starting with your shirt
are those sea horses on your shirt those
are geckos come here and see them
all right
well listen guys blend in um
[Music]
so are you ready to sing this song no
hey seriously seriously i've like
phillip you know
tonight is like i don't know what you're
on tonight but like
you're actually singing pretty good like
i wouldn't kick you off some of the
talent shows
which is a post in most times where i'm
usually like that's my friend
good thing he's [__] funny
guess what's your job guess what that's
because i didn't take a hundred
milligram edibles just 25.
[Applause]
oh cool more wheat joes
no i'm a responsible adult um okay
so uh you ready
all right let's see what you got
sounds like one of our songs it might be
oh and by the way i changed a couple
lyrics
that's okay so did i oh [__]
it was the first date that
my mom set up
it was uncomfortable
oh
i remember she told me
in her past life that she was a cat
and not only that she had three extra
toes
she lets her back hair grow
she was raising five little kids
from five different dicks i really want
to leave
but mom will be mad at me
so guess what
i'm gonna need weed
[Applause]
it's early in the morning
in a long line you know to get your
coffee
then
one person in front of you
she seems really confused what's in a
chai
are those muffins dry hey lady what the
[__]
have you never been to starbucks
there's a lot of an angry
mob going to tankless jobs and i forgot
the words
because i changed them up
so guess what
i don't need any more weed
[Applause]
[Music]
there comes a day
when
[Music]
toe
or run out of dough
you don't like your ass so you take a
bar class whatever your reason be
it's just enough for me guess what we're
gonna need way
hey
please don't tell any of the other guys
that i just did that are you kidding me
i'm live streaming with fatone right now
oh [__]
no the really weird part was i thought
we were doing this like three weeks ago
when you said we were yeah yeah so i had
the words memorized and over and over in
my head then they go hey we need you to
do this anti-drug thing in vegas can you
come out and sing it's gonna be me
nope
kris kirkpatrick everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
you know some songs i just think they
catch me and something happens during
the middle of the day where i'll write a
quick little jingle
and um
so this is the latest little one uh
there's the latest little one um he
knows what the [__] what am i talking
about
this is the latest little one i hope you
like
[Music]
i don't even know what [__] song
you're playing right now
yeah yeah
like it sure doesn't sound like anything
i've ever played before what is that
sounds great okay ready
in my car
driving around
music's up i am lost in the sounds
she pulls up
to my right
looks inside at just the wrong time and
she saw me pick a booger
i just picked a booger
that's all i got
[Applause]
it's hard to play that one off isn't it
where you're like
um
all right
it's like god bless
no i was telling you you had something
up your nose i was just trying to tell
you
um
all right this next song is something
that happened to me at my brother's
wedding
and uh
we'll see how it goes
[Music]
at my brother's wedding
talking to the dj
i was supposed to tell him about
songs that he could play
my brother likes hip hop
and he likes classic rock
he could get down to some r b
he likes to dance to some pile
[Music]
dj smiled at me
he said
don't you worry son
i've done this a hundred times i
guarantee he will have fun
but can you please tell me
are there any twos
i definitely should not play
you think we'll kill the mood and i said
whatever you do don't play hotel
california
i hate that [__] song
it's so goddamn long
and everyone here hates the hotel
california
not one single time
and not one [__] line
[Music]
the dj's stand right through me
his eyes went cold his eyes and he said
well i've been playing that song at
weddings since 1979
and who do you think that you are to
change my ways
i'll play hotel california and i'll also
play yfca
that's all i got for that song
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen
kirk chambers everybody out here
yeah one more time record everybody
all right guys we're just gonna
wrap it up with a couple quick songs and
we'll get everybody out of here um i uh
i can't believe okay
all right
so we're gonna try it in in me fashion
um it wouldn't be me doing something
like this without trying something brand
new so
um
yeah i know um
and i'm pretty sure i'm off i know the
lyrics to the song and we'll find out
real quick
so that i have a very anxious dog this
song escalates a little bit
well i have got a very anxious dog
he doesn't like to be alone and when you
leave he loses his mind
he's broken out of every kennel we
bought
but yeah he tears right through them the
last one he left the door on our bed
like a complete [__]
yeah
what you cherish
oh he'll eat
[Music]
he knows what matters most to you yeah
did i mention
he opens doors now
my dog is jason born is that the remote
you need for your brand new tv
are these your favorite shoes you mean
these that i chewed and i'm gonna [__]
in the corner
i just the [__] in the corner go clean
up my mess
oh it gets weird
[Music]
[Applause]
lately things have taken a weird turn
like early this morning i woke up with
his paw on my mouth
and he was staring right at me
yeah
heart eye contact
he licked my face
[Music]
slow and firm without consent yeah
are we doing this now
and i pick up your [__]
[Music]
i'm my dog's prison [__] i'm gonna [__]
up your house yes i will yes i will and
i'm gonna
pee on your couch yes i will yes i will
and i'm gonna bark at a black guy
people will think that you're racist
yeah you'll get cancelled
[Applause]
hey will you hold this for me
you're gonna be my bobby boucher
[Applause]
you can do it
uh this next song i'm
definitely gonna lose a few of you uh
but i'd always wanted to parody
a song three times in the same song
so here you go this one definitely
escalates also
[Music]
i should had kirk play this one
and i was walking
one day with my buddy
i was
walking
one day with my puppy
i saw my buddy
drinking coffee by himself
and so i called him
to see what he was doing he looked at
the phone
but he didn't pick up
dude that's me
[Applause]
it's me calling
you saw me
[Music]
me calling
i love my grandma
she's quite an old lady been in a
wheelchair
for 29 years
and then
one day
while watching tv
she reached for the remote control
fell out of her chair
and now she
[Music]
[Applause]
she's crawling
you know she
[Music]
if you if you didn't like that verse i'd
walk the [__] out for the next one
if you can't handle the comedy show you
know where it's not happening on the
[__] street see you later
by the way i'm serious this next verse
is really going to bother you if that
one did
but this actually happened to me
[Music]
i worked on a tv show
with a kid named corki
called life goes on
he was mentally challenged and then one
day
he couldn't remember his lines
and the
director
yelled what's wrong with him
do these rings
he's [__]
[Applause]
[Music]
by the way i did this song last night
and people started to sing along i'm
like you can't sing along with this boy
[__]
you yeah you can't still party you can't
sing along too you can't
but and i want to say can i'm going to
give you guys a little comedy nerd [__]
if i can
so
when you do comedy so much about timing
and your inflection and your words and
how you use them so i had to really
think about how i wanted to do this part
of the song so i've done it two
different ways i did it this way duties
re
right re-dotted and i did another way i
do i said dude he's
[__] now when i did it like that
people booed
and i'll tell you why because when i say
duties re
you guys are making the joke before i do
i don't gotta do [__]
so don't get mad at me you laughed
before i [__] said
[Laughter]
four songs we're gonna get out of here
babe i'm gonna play a song at the end
okay
you're gonna come on stage for the last
song
hey bobby
bobby
h2o thank you
that's that quality h2o thanks bobby
[Music]
all right
so people ask me a lot why i don't drink
i don't drink because i make bad life
decisions when i drink
uh you might be here with one of yours
tonight
so
we're just gonna end it up with these
four songs and here we go
george
what do i
is there already people out there
would you prefer two songs instead of
four four
three four
all right we're gonna do three
and here we go
i um i i wrote the song after i talked
to a girl i went to high school with
and um i remember her because we were
the last two virgins that we knew
and so i remember calling her on the
phone and telling her we should be each
others first
and she was like why i said first of all
we're both virgins
um we went to preschool together
and she was like what does that mean i
said well what that means is i've known
you forever you've known me forever
embarrassing things are going to happen
on the first time but we're like buddies
so i would rather something embarrassing
happens in front of you and i'm sure
you'd rather have some embarrassing
happen in front of me and she was like
you know you're right
it's a great idea we're going to be each
other's firsts so this song is how that
night went
and by the way guys like the song
doesn't go we [__] for four hours she
came 30 times like that's not the song
you know
that's not what i was singing about
[Music]
you said i'd be your first and
you'd be mine
we'd be together until the end of time
i laid her down and i
kissed her lips
jeans on jeans and
hips on hers
things were going just as we've planned
she was my girl and i was her man
yeah and right before we began
will i
yeah yeah
came in my
pants i
came right in my pants
oh please don't tell my friends
that i came in my pants
and she was good to me
said it could happen to anyone
she said she'd give it a second try
she called the first one a dry run
i set the mood just right
[Music]
and to make sure what happened last
night didn't happen again
i jerked off four times before she came
over and then i jerked off two more
times because i was a teenager
and i could do that back then
it
[__] felt great
[Applause]
if i were you i'd put a [__] cape on
went into my room
superhero
oh and she looks so pretty
she unbuttoned my pants no mess
hello kitty
yeah and then my hand brushed her titty
[Music]
and i
came on her
pants i
came on her lime green pants
what the [__] is going on
i'll never see a vagina at this rate
yeah
years went by
and we talked from
time to time
i met her husband at the reunion
[Music]
i really liked him he was a nice guy
he and i were about eight drinks in
when he smiled and he said
you know what man
i gotta tell you and he said with a grin
i know you
came in your
pants and now you came on her pants too
you know she tells all her friends
the guy on tv came in his pants
she started a facebook page
and it's called
sticky drawers
where you can tell funny stories about
sex
oh and believe me she's told yours
i wanted revenge i didn't know what to
do
we all got drunk and ended up in my room
they passed out first
that's a rookie move
[Applause]
so i
his pants too
and put that on your facebook page but
with a big old [__]
[Applause]
thank you
all right two quick ones sony you guys
remember the song by four non blondes it
goes hey
[Music]
yeah [__] finish it up i like it
[Applause]
that's your part
so obviously we do not need to rehearse
that
all right this happened to me when i was
a kid
[Music]
i woke up in morning when i was a kid i
wanted
i woke up one morning when i was a kid
i wanted to get some
breakfast on
maybe some eggs and bacon
and then i rubbed my eyes and put my
feet on the floor i looked down the
parent's door and i
saw
something little peculiar
it was my mom and my dad and they were
wrestling around and my mom she made
some pretty weird sounds and i screamed
at the top of my lungs get off my mouth
and i said
hey
you know the words
[Music]
thank you very much
let's bring the lovely and talented
bethany ashton wolf out here bethany
come on
are you not
right through here brothers
come on up here
[Applause]
thanks for wearing my favorite pants
what's happening now we
we talked about father's day
and how easy it is uh
to get a present and so this is just in
case can i bobby
[Applause]
thank you so much so this is just in
case
for anybody who actually does want to
get a gift for their man in their life i
thought i'd write a little song
it's pretty easy
uh but so
you know i would tell you that beth is
an amazing gift giver
like she researches gifts
she's one of those people that'll
research a gift for like 60 days when
you open it you're like did you talk to
my third grade teacher like what the
[__]
but the gifts are amazing
and i always tell her man
you it took you 60 days you wasted 59
days
gifts for guys are easy
so this is a song for anybody looking to
get a gift for that special man in their
life
i hope this helps
a couple people catching on to the joke
already all right
that's all right everybody look if
you're at my show and you're looking for
my jokes they're right [__] here
they're not if you're looking around for
them you're going to miss them they're
coming right the [__] out your face
song for anybody and then guys thank you
so much for coming out tonight this will
be it for us
[Applause]
you're always so thoughtful
gifts on my special day
asking friends and family
about things that make me feel great
let me try to help you
let me
ease your mind
[Music]
cause it's pretty easy
you just have to ask us
we'll [__] tell you
[Music]
i just want a [__] and a sandwich
let me save you some time i'd like a
[__]
and a sandwich i don't need another
[__] tie
and i have one work alone since the
eighth grade you and your sister use the
couple's massage i'd like a loja
and a sandwich
at the same time
tiny tiny tiny tiny tiny tiny time
[Music]
i like turkey on wheat
i like ham on rye
to make this day complete
well there's one more thing that i'd
like to try
now i know when guys say try
women always think that we're talking
about anal
because that's true
[Music]
just not this time
i just like a blue jaw and a sandwich
while i'm watching tv
turn on espn
little predators highlights
watching grown men skate around in tight
pants
[Music]
now i know on your special day
i'd give you anything that you need
trips jewelry or clothing
i'd bring the moon down to its knees
she doesn't have to tell me
cause i know what she really wants
because she's told me before
[Music]
i've still never done it
you'll see why
she says she wants me naked we're
washing dishes
in a ryan gosling mess
wrong folks in the break
telling all of our friends
quotes from the notebook over again
i wrote her every single day
[Music]
what guns n roses song is like this
patience
all right let me see if i can do this
dude's voice at the end of the show but
we'll try we're going to end it with
patience and we're going to get
everybody out here
[Applause]
all right patience right
[Music]
you ready babe
i love you
thanks i love your pants
a [__] and a sandwich
a [__] and a sand
[Music]
[Applause]
i promise not to get any crumbs on your
head i just wanna blow job while i watch
some tv
that'll feel so fine to me in a [__]
yeti in a sandwich
is
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you all so much for coming out
here tonight
[Applause]